[Music]
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 62.
and welcome to hannity this busy news
making friday night 62 days our fellow
americans their families our friends
green card holders our allies joe biden
abandoned all of them
oh and he hasn't talked about them in
over 40 days and now the images coming
out of afghanistan they are horrific
everything we told you would happen look
at these pictures obtained by
congressman michael waltz showing one
female afghan national soldier bloody
and bruised after a severe beating by
the taliban terrorists they broke her
arms and they broke her ribs congressman
waltz will join us tonight and that's
not all coming up we'll show you a truly
disgusting video of young kids
purportedly murdered by the taliban now
these are not the business-like
professional diplomats as characterized
by biden and his spin meister on
propagandist jensaki now these are evil
terrorists and joe oh this week he
announced uh yeah if you're part of the
taliban from the old regime you're
welcome to america we'll take you off
the terror watch list these are people
now that are going house to house
identifying any person that was allied
with us
murdering entire families men women and
children and their rain or terror is
ripping through the entire country joe
biden hasn't said one single word about
the people he abandoned in over 45 days
joe biden isn't just incompetent and a
cognitive mess he's also frankly morally
bankrupt and vile and yes john androsic
is right he has blood on his hands and
now his inflation is spiraling out of
control well joe's out there hawking
four trillion dollars in new spending
lecturing all of us that we've got to
pay our fair share you know what we are
paying our fair share we're paying more
for everything and we'll pay more for
energy and oil the lifeblood of the
world's economy is you beg opec
to produce more oil you're the one that
made us energy dependent again you are
handed energy independence and secure
borders and a real plan to get everybody
out of afghanistan safely take a look
i'm a capitalist but guess what i'm also
enlisted for 36 years the poorest man in
the congress
but i make big money now i'm a president
you know when i talked to all your folks
out in the playground and as i joked and
saw everybody knows i like kids better
than people
fortunately they'll like me that's why
maybe i like them and be honest with you
we're probably not going to get 3.5
trillion this year we're going to get
something less than that
but i'm going to negotiate i'm going to
get it done with the grace of god and
good little neighbors and the crick
knight rises my grandpa would say
i'm glad they made a profit
keep with the boy i mean that sincerely
but pay
your fair share
pay your fair share by the way market
watch uh consumer confidence in biden's
economic policies
i don't think you can get any lower than
that now how about you start with your
own family joe own family how about zero
experience hunter you know your son
under federal investigation for tax
fraud and money laundering you should
know all about it he had a shared bank
account and by the way you're the big
guy right that was supposed to get your
cut uh does your son hunter pay his fair
share joe do you pay your fair share and
by the way americans are already feeling
the effect of biden's recent spending
spree just look at your screen
everything you buy is now more expensive
gas up 42 percent furniture up double
digits bacon i love bacon up 20 percent
steak 22 percent want to rent a car 42
percent higher used cars 24 percent
higher new car eight percent higher if
you can find one propane up 27
he's making putin rich again with his
waiver uh appliances seven percent putin
in his case it's natural gas and the
list goes on and on and on in september
u.s wholesale prices rose a whopping 8.6
that is a record increase from
wholesalers and guess what that will get
passed on to you the consumer who gets
impacted the most poor people middle
class americans they get the biden tax
increases because they are getting hurt
the most according to the master
puppeteer the ever compassionate biden's
chief of staff ron klain inflation is a
high class problem uh oh okay a high
class problem impacting the poor
impacting the middle class in other
words the people that make this country
great the forgotten men and women that
you lied to and said they wouldn't pay a
penny in new taxes you know we smelly
walmart shoppers that cling to god our
guns our bibles and religion those
people me in other words reality nearly
every major economist in the u.s is now
sounding the alarm larry summers this is
obama's chief economic advisor warning
we are in more danger than we have been
in during my career of losing control of
inflation in the u.s there is a
gathering storm of inflation the main
risk is that our economy is going to
overheat and once it overheats it's
going to be hard to put out the fire
without doing a a lot of damage and
causing a lot of problems jp morgan ceo
also warning that inflation might go
higher than people expect even democrat
chuckie schumer he's whining and
complaining now he supports all these
idiotic policies and new green deal
socialism and he's complaining that his
constituents will soon be forced to
choose between buying food and heating
their homes
actually one of the rare times he said
something that's truthful take a look
there's a new worry
that with every touch of our thermostats
this winter
many seniors and working families will
also have to reach much deeper into
their pockets
so given that it's my job to turn up the
heat on the federal government before
this worry manifests itself into real
trouble
no family should have to choose
between heating their home or putting
food on the table but that was a lot of
people particularly seniors wait a
minute joe biden's puppeteer said this
is a high class problem right wrong
claim by the way senator schumer you
have control of the senate you have
control of the house you have control of
the white house these are your problems
that you've created along with joe biden
now to make matters even worse america's
supply chain as we've been telling you
is in tatters we have billions and
billions of dollars worth of products
now stuck at ports now some containers
aren't even able to come on shore
massive backlogs in both california and
new york now bare shelves biden hashtag
bare shells biden it's trending all over
twitter americans posting pictures of
stores that are pretty much empty empty
shelves anyway get this a report from
reuters our supply chain is too snarled
for biden's christmas fix in other words
good luck getting the presents that your
kids are begging for from santa probably
not going to happen but according to
transportation secretary the ever
compassionate mayor pete who said to
pink slipped keystone xl pipeline
workers just get another job yeah that
guy with all that compassion and
experience the mayor of south bend well
if you didn't do your christmas shopping
three months early you're just flat out
of luck
explain that to a to a young child the
young boy or girl that boy didn't get
his train set the girl didn't get her
doll we're going to say oh it's a supply
chain
santa didn't go shopping early enough
take a look
supply chain issues how bad are they
going to get for americans and i'm
talking specifically you know leading
here into the december holidays where
people are relying on getting goods on
getting presents
well i think there's always been two
kinds of christmas shoppers they're the
ones who have all their list completed
by halloween and then there's people
like me who show up at the mall on
christmas eve if you're in that ladder
bucket obviously there's going to be
more challenges
yeah you could say to your daughter i
know you wanted that special doll and
you asked santa for the last six months
um but the problem is santa didn't go
shopping early enough to get the doll
i thought the elves made it
jenn stockey took it a step further she
wants to you to blame ups and fedex it's
not our problem we're not ups we're not
we're not fedex
it's your problem take a look
can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce
delays
oh such compassion from all these
liberals and the white house
propagandists great compassion there
it's not our fault you know blame ups
blame fedex blame everybody but joe
pretty strange thing to say
because in 2020 then candidate joe biden
he talked an awful lot about supply
chain issues and shortages and he said
we don't have a shortage problem we have
a leadership problem
actually joe biden he got lucky he got
it right for once he was right in 2020.
leadership problem is him not trump
you know
i want to make clear to all your
listeners
that we don't have a food shortage
problem
we have a leadership problem one of the
reasons why we're not getting
material and food to people's tables is
because there's no way to get it
transported to there we don't know how
to manage what's going on no the
leadership problem wasn't then we had
secure borders energy independence we
had lower taxes we didn't have an
inflation problem and we he gave you
also let's see not one not two but three
vaccines and monoclonal antibodies that
you never mentioned till two and a half
weeks ago you inherited a country with
the economy fully on the men all the
vaccines all the therapeutics like
monoclonal antibodies a secure border
energy independence a stable afghanistan
and joe you ruined it all we have a
leadership problem under biden many
economists now fear a looming recession
according to peter navarro in the new
york post welcome back to 70 style
stagflation misery thanks to uncle joe
peter will join us in a moment add to
this biden's vaccine mandates oh when
they hit watch out what impact is that
going to have on the economy and now
causing american uh americans to
they're willing to get fired
it looks like half the police department
in chicago they're not going to be
working as of next week and it's going
to get worse thousands of our military
personnel nurses and first responders
and health care professionals you know
the people in the middle of the covet
shift show in march and april of 2020
that every day walked into a petri dish
of of covet and were diving on covert
grenades
to save fellow americans lives in the
early months of this pandemic they're
gonna now we're gonna fire them i guess
that's joe biden's way of saying what
thank you because they don't agree with
the mandate maybe they have a rare
condition maybe they believe in national
that natural immunity i'm not here to
debate the shot or not but the reality
is you're going to lose some of the best
people that risked their lives to save
fellow human beings fellow americans
lives but i guess joe doesn't know about
that because he abandoned americans in
afghanistan 13 days after he said he
wouldn't half the chicago police force
might be forced to go very soon we've
got hundreds of airline employees
they're facing termination thousands of
teachers thousands of u.s service men
and women uh have or will be fired in
coming weeks you have state employees
you've got federal employees members of
the military employees at large private
corporations all facing termination if
they don't comply with the mandate but
joe biden refused to answer any
questions about all this